we begin in the united states where tens
of thousands of people have joined
rallies across the country in support of
abortion rights the marches were
galvanized by a restrictive law in the
state of texas that severely limits
access to abortions they also took place
two days ahead of the start of a new
term for the conservative supreme court
protesters fear that the justices could
strip federal protections for women
seeking safe abortions
[Music]
thousands flocked to washington in the
first women's march of president joe
biden's administration
heading straight to the steps of the u.s
supreme court protesters demanded
continued access to abortion
the demonstration took place ahead of
the start of a new term for the high
court that will decide the future of
abortion rights
it's beyond important it's not a young
woman issue it's a person issue and if
anyone does not have equal rights in
this country that means no one has equal
rights what's going on in texas has
twofold problem
first of all it's tyranny over women but
the second thing is it's inspiring
people
to make reports about their neighbors
and people they come in contact with
there should be federal legislation i'm
a citizen in the united states not a
citizen of texas not a citizen of
georgia the pro-choice rallies held
across the u.s on saturday were sparked
by the so-called heartbeat act in texas
the law severely restricts access to
abortion and anybody involved in helping
a woman terminate a pregnancy after six
weeks can be sued
i'm sick and tired of having to fight
over abortion rights it's settled law in
the nation and you are not taking that
right away from us
not now not ever
[Music]
and my heart goes out
to the places the women in places
like texas and georgia and missouri and
so many others
counter protesters also held rallies but
were heavily outnumbered by people
demanding full access to abortion
politicians in republican-led u.s states
are considering similar measures to
those introduced in texas which has
effectively banned most abortions since
early september
well dw correspondent stefan simons has
been covering that rally for us which is
now wrapping up at the u.s supreme court
hi chef and good to see you
what's the atmosphere been like on the
streets of washington today
well just a few minutes ago it was a
little bit raucous because as you can
see here in the background those are
actually pro-life protesters so
anti-abortion protesters this is a some
kind of church group there they're
praying a lot uh for the
uh
for taxes and for the the law which bans
abortion so and of course uh the
anti-abortion restriction protesters um
met this group and other groups down the
street and it got a little bit of
contentious a lot of some kind of yell
fest however overall this was uh up to
20 000
anti-abortion restriction protesters
making
um giving voice their their their anger
or their um their will to fight the
texas law the most
restrictive abortion law in the country
and of course they uttered their
fear or concern that other states in the
united states will pick this up alabama
mississippi and so on
some states in the in in the south uh
the east and in the south um
now they went home it is dispersed they
only had a license
for for three hours where they could be
here and now everything is cleared just
those guys here praying for the absence
of any abortions ever
are still here
all right well tell us
the protests and the campaign against
restricting abortion can can they really
make any impact
i
think
yes in in terms of motivating
visually motivating the
the crowd people who are uh
really have a problem with the latest
law in in texas with uh being stripped
of basically their right uh of abortion
um
so yeah this will motivate more and more
people probably at least that's what the
organizers hope uh to come out and make
their voices heard now how do they make
their voices heard uh not by just
marching up and down the street of
course that's nice for visual and for us
for television and for them to show they
are there they are forced but it's of
course with their votes and with money
because it is politicians who are
pushing laws restrictive or less
restrictive in regards to abortion
through a senate and
to a governor's desk or let's say even
to a president's desk or
here to the supreme court right behind
me this is where everybody fears will
this fight end up sooner or later rather
later i guess but it will end up here in
the supreme court now very
conservatively stacked by donald trump
who appointed two conservative judges to
the court um we'll have to decide what
happens to roe versus raid or the
constitutional right of abortion
all right stefan simons in washington
thank you for your reporting
right in the mouth
[Music]
raquel fatio was only 22 when her life
changed dramatically 10 years ago
somebody kind of just will put something
in my drink they think it was ketamine
which is the horse tranquilizer
and then
i ended up in this car this person kept
threatening me over and over because i
kept screaming and said
you know spread your legs
or do you want to die
a few weeks later she was raped a second
time this time by her boyfriend it was
10 weeks into her pregnancy that she
made the decision to have an abortion
not only like seeing that person's face
every day but
how do you explain that to that child
that their father
the reason you know they were born is
because their father
violated their
mother raquel lives in texas where a law
bends most abortions as early as six
weeks that's before most women even know
they are pregnant there is no exception
for rape or incest
it opens the door for almost any private
citizen to sue not only abortion
providers but also supportive family
members and even taxi drivers who give
women a ride to the clinic
brian hughes is the republican state
senator who wrote the law which will
likely start a national trend
so in a horrible unspeakable situation
like a rape
i hope no one is suggesting that if a
woman went through that if she had an
abortion that would make everything okay
the women we've heard from some who
chose abortion
and some who chose to keep the child
have all told us how difficult what a
hard situation that was so we have a
difficult situation already let's don't
make it worse by punishing the child we
don't punish the unborn child we punish
the rapist
the anti-abortion law is specifically
hard for women in texas just because of
the pure size of this state driving to a
clinic in arizona for example where
abortion is still allowed might take up
to 20 hours that is not only adding
extra costs but making it extremely
difficult for women who are without
financial
or emotional support
we are driving quite far to a secret
location in texas to speak to a doctor
who is facing death threats for
providing abortion services
to protect his identity he asked us to
only film him from behind
there's an increased threat to doctors
who provide these services
there have been doctors in the past who
have been murdered doing these
procedures
and with the political climate the way
it is right now
there's a lot of tension in particular
trying to provide these services
procedures were available for women up
until 21.6 weeks into their pregnancy
so when you basically narrow it down to
six weeks you have excluded probably 80
to 90 percent of what patients would
normally be able to get services in the
state of texas sometimes women will try
uh self-induced stuff abortion so they
will go to any type of extreme
to go ahead and to see if they can quote
abort themselves and which would happen
sometimes there can be basically you
know
even
maternal fatalities and we have people
on the outside who are judging these
women and are telling these women what
they what they should do holy mary
mother god
all over texas members of evangelical
churches are praying that the new law
doesn't get overruled they are
applauding the fact that hardly any
abortions have been carried out since it
was enacted i know when there's trauma
and a woman experiences something like
rape or incest that there's already one
victim and that the majority of the time
the women that turn around and think
that an abortion is going to fix it it
only compounds the problem and makes it
worse
so i don't think that there should be an
additional victim to try to solve that
problem because you can't undo that and
it's already one trauma
if the current law had been in place
when raquel was raped 10 years ago it is
very likely that she would not have been
able to live the self-determined happy
family life she does today all right
here we go